[Musique]
ce village de 600 habitants est située à
la frontière du gard et de l'ardèche au
coeur des cévennes et comme tous les
villages de la région il se réveille à
l'heure des châtaignes
quand la coque piquante de celle ci les
bugs éclate sur le tapis rouge de
l'automne les forêts de châtaigniers
couvre les cévennes et sont la
principale ressource du pays
un don du ciel une manne en quelque
sorte qu'il faut seulement se pencher
pour cueillir le ramassage a lieu en
octobre et en novembre
armé d'une baguette pour écarter les
bobs du pis quand cette jeune fille mais
les châtaignes dans un cageot alors que
les vieux cons servent l'ancienne
méthode de ramassage mettant les fruits
dans le bias ou qui est le sac de jute
accroché à la taille
les sacs de châtaignes prennent ensuite
la route des marchés qui se tiennent
spécialement à cette occasion un peu
partout dans l'ardèche notamment à vals
les bains à la bégude à aubenas et à
privas surtout qui est le principal
centre utilisateurs de châtaignes c'est
souvent le garde champêtre qui fait
fonction de buzzer jurés et quand un
acheteur après palabres après discussion
d'un un bout de papier aux vendeurs à la
vendeuse ici est bien c'est que
l'affairé conclue au prix indiqué sur la
feuille et c'est par tonne que les
châtaignes sont enfin expédié dans les
confiseries de l'ardèche première région
productrice de france
les châtaignes deviennent alors des
marrons glacés ou en crème qui seront
envoyés un peu partout dans le monde
mais en france leur a déjà sonné des
marrons chauds qui font les deere +2
[Musique]